[Music]
all this week we've been jumping stupid
things across the world famous state
street driveway
yeah it's been fun
yeah
first
first we jumped a 10-foot bratwurst
which made it
the next night we unsuccessfully tried
to jump a replica of the picasso
sculpture
it crashed and sank
on our next attempt mrs o'leary's cow
made the leap
is that a hitch
well
it's time to up the annie
thank you
tonight
tonight we're staging a competition
first let's see one of chicago's icons
mr t let's see if he can make the jump
it's there it is it's a replica
it's a replica of mr t
the real one refused to risk his life
for this
of course mr t held the title of
chicago's toughest bouncer
then he went on to star as ba barakas on
the a team
who can forget his long work as
cleverlang and rocky iii
if you're a fool he will pity you
let's see how mr t does
[Applause]
one
yes let's go
[Applause]
yes
[Applause]
oh my god
technically he made it
let's see a replay it looked like he
landed on his mohawk
he does get a good run he makes the jump
but i think a little too much gas
he flips
and
all right
well i've got to tell you mr t
real mr t you made the right choice
[Laughter]
he said i'm not doing that
well as i said tonight is a competition
all right mr t technically made it but
he made it look easy
let's find out how an obese tourist from
green bay handles the jump
there he is
wearing his iconic cheesehead hat
riding
his rascal scooter
this man loves to go to chicago bars and
talk loudly about the packers super bowl
victories
[Music]
[Applause]
let's see if he can make the jump
he's full of confidence
this is exciting
five
four
three
two
one
go jesus
[Music]
oh my god
usa
wait a minute
wisconsin's in the united states
we show those foreigners
all right
let's
we've never had this feature until
tonight let's watch that spectacular
crash from our exclusive fat green bay
fan handlebar camera
and there he goes
and oh my god
wow
[Applause]
did you see that the minute he saw he
wasn't going to make it he just gave up
uh graceful acceptance of death all
right